[Music]
and that's excessive news all excessive
exceptive submitted by king taco is the
best any absolutely not I like it but I
do appreciate that you guys are open
really late and you have a coverage not
oily that's what's the part that I keep
yeah this isn't a fan on their meat no
they don't
I would track macros so they don't have
a [ __ ] on us of who we are it's not bad
to Intendant ah you know what quality is
not a great another great I like the way
they marinate their meat so I'm with
Jill rely me yes a California couple
sues the police for wrecking their house
just to capture a homeless man oh this a
restaurant hair like they like
superheroes like you know when they're
trying to save that left town or
whatever then they start fighting and
they [ __ ] break down all the [ __ ]
buildings and you [ __ ] up the road like
we thought oh yeah so this incident
actually took place last year the reason
why this news right now is because this
friend milk hub wall decided to file a
lot it is we don't 9-1-1
damn this took place in Fresno town
can you pull a gun on a cop if he just
breaks into your house I don't know
freeze [ __ ] you're not going to
destroy my [ __ ] house trying to catch
homeless yeah did the homeless man run
into the healthy yeah how did this
happen was even in this so this took
place in Fresno County and David's home
was completely trashed after the police
raided it and so what did the police do
you thought the homeless man was hiding
in trash cans I just didn't tell to them
no so there was this homeless man that
was actually in this house that was
vacant that was right next to the
homeowner David's house oh that was the
wrong house so no no so so the homeless
man he was in a vacant home and so
construction workers were actually going
in there he liked to do some work on the
top yeah so he was a squatter and so
like they're shooing this homeless man
away right
and so this homeless man actually goes
and he decides to break into David's
home whoa okay and so here is a David's
home and so that's when the police were
called and so the Weaver called in and
about four officers were there and they
were just trying to handle the situation
right and so they decided to call David
like hey there's a homeless man in your
home right and so David goes back to his
house and the police officer was asking
him like okay is there anything in your
home that you have what you have any
weapon and so he said that he had two
unloaded shotguns and a handgun and so
when the police officers were yelling at
this homeless man saying like hey come
out hands up the homeless man didn't
want to come out and they're just like
like he was pretty much threatening is
like oh you know like I'm gonna shoot
you right homeless man was a no-no
homeless man was saying it because no no
so the homeless man was saying it he was
like Bernie's a guy if anyone tries to
come inside like I'll shoot you guys
right and so at that point that's when
the police was like okay David can you
please leave so that we can take care of
the situation right and so David was
like what does my [ __ ] house
well I mean he complied because David
actually tried to get get into his house
like he got the house can you turn to
unlock it but the homeless man lost it
and also they had a that's my mouth I
looked a there and so and so the police
like well David wasn't home during this
incident right David had to get there
yeah David had to get the because o
because the police called him over and
so did that pollutes asked him to leave
yeah they asked them to me so that they
can take care of it and so then um I'm
staying there oh just watch like why do
I have to leave because the Christian
dangerous because I just watch from down
the street I don't have to leave I would
be so [ __ ] irritated if I put my key
into my [ __ ] keyhole I go by the
black locks I'm like oh no baby what
this [ __ ] like it okay I try to tell
the police yo police you guys's because
I got this situation taken care of when
I have the dead body you guys come and
pick his ass up are you going with him a
[ __ ] sandwich out the door do you
still stay outside of your house
knowing the fact that he may pretend to
have a gun on him because if you don't
know my Gerber shooter I got guns hidden
under rock maybe it had him because we
know David's are dumb
on the wall like mounted like claw was
for everybody to grab the police
officers didn't know if the homeless man
had his own gun or if he encountered one
of David's guns but then David was
saying like no I've hidden the gun so
well that no one could find that where
is it under my pillow this is I don't
know I've never stated but so like the
officers total terrific hey what will
take care of it right and so they was
like to secure it right so he pulled his
wife and he told a family about okay so
like let's all relocate to a friend's
house
in the mean time right and the friend's
house was only about 10 minutes away
right so all of my events was informed
so Heyman is family they go over to his
friends house and then David he had like
a whole bunch of farm equipment in his
truck so he decides to drive back home
just to drop it off but on his way back
he saw a [ __ ] ton of SWAT card and
police car and soul and he's all like um
he saw a fire truck and then why don't
you think that this is the perfect
moment for him to go and return [ __ ] so
home like you probably be done
maybe it wasn't it will just give stupid
David the credit and benefit of the
doubt and stupid David was just like all
right I need any excuse to go back home
so I could see what's going on or maybe
you could have bit his family in the car
cook yet old equipment in either way he
had to jump off equipment and he saw all
like all these cars going over this
house was on fire and so he was like
what the heck is going on he's going to
and then he won and he like drove back
to where the rest of his family is at
and so a a few hours later he gets a
call from the officers like saying hey
you come back home now like if
everything is all cool right and so he
goes back home and everything is just
destroying like walls were torn down
door who ripped off like when walls were
torn down
yeah I'm going out a one-guy speech
route yeah each room with like near
labor was tear gas like there's a lot of
tear gas to the point I nobody could
live in it I would
what does like spend thousands and
thousands of dollars to try to catch a
guy a homeless guy they could've just
thrown a sandwich and clean underwear
and like a cup of change and I got what
I came right out yeah like I wanted a
club a homeless dude and they're like
David so we have a sandwich outside some
clean underwear and some breath mints
and a twenty bucks come outside so
you're gonna leave that brand new home
you just got you just got yourself in a
loser friend you wait I'm not going to
live it forever obviously but if they
enticed me with a sandwich I mean that
other sandwich the police department is
not pay for any of that [ __ ] so
apparently the state has to pay Penn
State they have to what Commission's
like knock the door down and then let a
police dog inside yeah do you come out
quit yet they had a k-9 unit yeah they
could have just stopped look at his eyes
down like one second I think they were
just going over I think in this town in
Fresno nothing was happening
they're like sadly we gotta use a SWAT
yeah that stuff was a lawsuit is
claiming is like they found like they
felt the SWAT team and like the police
department she'll like it was the
opportune location to like actually run
a drill oh my god so they're saying like
yeah like to like run a drill and then
also like to you you know those
resources so do you think there was
really a homeless person there there was
a limit on Tiger yeah
it was it kind of user excuse just to go
full for to see what it's like I got a
helicopter about didn't you were
probably gonna didn't even try to like
offer compensation or like trying to
help clean up the house oh as soon as
David got back to his home right he was
encountered by two officers one officer
said that the operation was concluded
and then another officer handed
David a card and verbally saying we have
insurance for this well but the thing is
that this is David word saying that like
this officer said that we have insurance
for this so I don't know if they
actually said it or not but or do you
know what the card immediately start
taking pictures
up finding a lawyer have them come over
while everything's [ __ ] up [ __ ] out of
you better give me a nicer house there's
a lot of things that just cost it's not
worth money but it's like worth more
than money like what if they [ __ ] up
family pictures what if they [ __ ] up
things that were passed down for
generations yeah there's just a lot of
things that you just can't rebuy damages
were more than a hundred fifty without
radiologists whole whole that's not like
a boo ship do that the whole house in
Fresno dude yeah
they can't even live in that you got
some mouth not a nice house don't know
suing the police the police department
yeah because they're just like well it
was like unnecessary action like
sandwiches can cure a lot of problems
dude it was that a faithful friend they
didn't even try to get their insurance
and already there I I don't I don't know
that information what I'm assuming what
I'm assuming is because like because of
reasons why they're having the sausages
like maybe they're like Walt
maybe the insurance didn't come through
yeah maybe there's not enough money yeah
cuz your homeowners insurance is like
fire earthquake not against the police
blowing it up it'll by police insures
yeah no one buys insurance for [ __ ]
police agents believe it ain't blowing
it up just looking crazy do that that's
all hardly [ __ ] though the cops just
decided let's [ __ ] with these like who's
protecting you from the cop yeah and the
homeless person only took an ice cream
bar milk and half a tomato I told you if
you Jermaine uh offered him a sandwich
you could have got him out only took
what the ice cream you want hungry
hungry ice cream bar milk and just buy a
double-double some fries put a right
outside what it came outside of the
second that's not like a good idea
that's uh I knew it I told you I know
homeless people did you guys enjoyed
that episode of just kitty news if you
did please leave a comment down below
and share us your thoughts and your
feelings for more episodes click right
up here
[Music]